how's it going everyone and welcome to
through the porthole I this is a custom
story and I think it one like third best
custom story on frictional games website
that's pretty cool it should be good
I just woke up I'm like I feel like a
zombie I'm ready father
look we went through the portal and I
guess we came here or something I don't
know I don't know but we have the
lantern already wow this is pretty epic
Ryan mines me a half-life for those it's
stuck already with those finger leading
me I wonder if the mall sitter is there
through the portal most likely the [ __ ]
is going on here Monica I thought I
could use them I want Scully I doubt
we'll find Stephano in this place I mean
whatever could it possibly
here okay so I guess we could go through
here but I need the key and I have the
key let's go
are you [ __ ] kidding me there we go
made me worried to that for a minute no
life is key
oh wait man
Allah this loading screen is longer than
the first note oh crap
what's going on it's not wasting this
mushroom is huge I wonder if I could
jump here no I can't jump on them [ __ ] I
got stuck on the mushrooms really I want
to take a bite or armpit or whatever
see that's the biggest mushroom I've
ever seen let's go in here
I'm great I can't open
yeah this looks fun [ __ ] tastic
[Music]
the [ __ ] was that
ari was a
that's kind of creepy let's go here
boxes and [ __ ] it's down here
a bug
beautiful new bucket again
so it's point of this place
come here brah
come on do I really need to take you
this
jumpity-jump touch it to Joe
wow that looks [ __ ] weird the other
world limp advised activating yeah yeah
avian harder my love I am doing terrible
things for you that's well sis
I'm not certain the acquisition of this
fighter will even bring you back I am
leaving today towards for in such a more
shame on myself in US and my deepest
sorrow for the next puppet I use still I
would destroy the lives of our know if
that is what it takes
Aleksandra we will be reunited Jessie
[Music]
dead cause it's I mean that people in
the car dead what barrels I know you
would be rare what are you doing here
pals forever ever forever
I hate barrels and hate barrels so
[ __ ] much can't even barrels blocking
the shit's nice logs how there we go
there we go oh nothing in it haha
[ __ ] great
but is this anyway
otherworldly device activated okay okay
[ __ ] outers and stuff really weird
let's go in here this is a ouch
the strange device is quiet a nearby
door
let's break it
actually the barrel might come in use
my election II this peril I need my
worst enemy it's not true okay I'm just
gonna collaborate this one [ __ ] time
barrel I didn't like but it was
breakable in the other mod I play sad
face
maybe the plates do you want them you
been alive plates [ __ ] wait here's
something Power Core another Power Core
and third cat power cord court really
really really uh maybe you ain't just
rival obviating still anything am i
allowing you to read uh-huh this again
small aversion all
why not would have been perfect
barrels
yes oh cool I only need one [ __ ] is that
sound
[Music]
okay it's pretty safe
we're out of the air
a moment let's chick Momentis find a way
back home
flee of your past okay let's do it
what is this I love scissors but my mom
said not to play with them hahaha I can
finally do it anyway
comparisons of realm for a nunnery era
it's tiny enough are like the last
example the beings of the rainfall
appear to be unable to compile some of
our basic wildlife one of the travelers
why are as he called was completely
oblivious to a wild camp gank whatever
the aquatic cousin of the lag he
explained that he that was simply no way
she want to go along with effects of
camp had on its environment possibly the
tabla hunters the meanest despite the
pain I caused of tidal yields such
interesting data I will flow acquainting
lay harmful
the [ __ ] where am I
why is this guy orange a doorway is
worth today I ever had
oh my head hurts ever suppose it barrels
the barrels knew it the parents get me
whoa uh-oh never mind
beware
this is splash a little nightcap good
anyway now we can go yeah no we can't go
[Music]
Oh
oh we need more for power cords of
course we need power cords it's fun in
there bro Saito
yeah
here
mushrooms no focus no mushrooms so
pretty
sorry no focus well it's [ __ ] after
me uh-oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] against both ah what
do you want from me it's not that I
think you're gonna do anything
Oh side face don't stop mushroom push
push it's like a Polaroid picture why
what what doesn't calm attribute okay we
good
mushrooms arrow huh bud
I just want to go I wanna go close the
door close the door close the door
closer oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
I could do all / all right oh sorry
really don't try you cannot use item
this way the [ __ ] how do you want me to
use that I would assume we can't go here
nope this door likes penis
[ __ ] my legs are itching let's go here
it's Fire Department
ah it's the unfoldment oh can we go can
we lately
no no let's go anyway
that's pretty cool but we can't go so
Saturdays
so that's how I did it
but
[ __ ] its itching a lot why why why why
why what do you want for me why boys we
go back maybe I missed something along
the way or something I don't know could
have been cut a bit like that I saw this
and I'm like what is this but I never
actually bothered to look at it no
there's definitely nothing here
besides mushrooms
now what
Oh bro my bro
what did they do to you pity you're
finally here
I've been waiting for you fear they you
need to continue to me I'm for you have
to say was pity it's all up to you no
bro don't die on me bro DNA I want you
to know that only I chased you only
because I love you and I wanted to make
out with you and have sex
maybe later Oh bro bro that's [ __ ]
disgusting beauty don't go from Paree
that's such a good actor
[Music]
yeah ask me what it feel like seven a
disguise so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie they say real like I'll be making
good on my promises honesty is pop it
inside of it is listen but I realize I
can't be better than I was later on my
feet cooking up the soul when we fire up
the